Montana
nécessaire
[musique]
Je n'ai pas vu une telle foule depuis longtemps
l'armée russe n'occupe pas
Territoire ukrainien
prend toutes les mesures pour sauver la vie
et sécurité
les civils soulignent que les frappes
ne s'applique qu'aux installations militaires et
armes de précision exceptionnelles
[musique]
nos militaires se battent immédiatement
tenez-vous bien, vous avez raison
leur argent même après avoir blessé des soldats et
l'officier reste en ligne veut dire que
une opération militaire spéciale est en cours
dans le strict respect de l'échéancier selon le plan
toutes les tâches assignées
résolu avec succès
[musique]
notre
[applaudissements]
à lui